birds are known for their numerous ways
of communicating sound body language or
in one case a strange combination of
both
crusted pigeons are indigenous to
Australia aside from their wicked
Mohawks there doesn't seem to be
anything too special about them that is
until they take to the air when the
crested pigeon flaps its wings they
whistle with each wing beat the upstroke
produces a 1.3 kilohertz low note and
the down stroke produces a 2.9 kilohertz
I know
[Music]
while this whistle has been known for
some time scientists were curious was
this just a quirk of biology or a method
of communicating the distinctive sound
was discovered to be coming from the
eighth feather on the pigeons wing when
this feather was removed from the bird
the high note disappeared along with it
and when the feather was placed in a
wind tunnel the high-frequency sound was
heard once again when the researchers
played back audio recordings of slow
wing beats the birds stayed where they
were but when they played faster wing
beats the birds were more likely to try
and flee because the notes cycle back
and forth between high and low the speed
of the cycle informs the pigeons whether
there is danger present or if it's just
another bird taking off this discovery
means that even though the crusted
pigeon isn't much of a talker there are
more ways for birds to communicate
audibly not with their mouths but with
their movements
[Music]